Thank you.
Good morning, everyone.
We've reached the lonely time of the year when many people are around still trying to put finishing touches on pieces of what's going on.
So you notice that the table is remarkably empty.
Thank heavens, Representative Umberger didn't want me to be alone.
LBA came up Umberger didn't want me to be alone.
LBA came up.
They didn't want me to be alone.
We are going to take a break, and I would ask LBA to post that until 11 o'clock this morning.
So we're officially on break.
Thank you.
Okay.
okay the time is now 1101 we've been on a break people are working on paperwork and having meetings you notice we still do not have a full table so rather than have people hang out 30 minutes at a time how about i tell you lovely people that we will break till one o'clock so you can have some lunch and not sit here and starve rather than pushing it 30 minutes at a time because i'm not sure exactly how quickly we will be ready so we're going to be in break until one o'clock the republican members from the house will be caucusing at 12 30 so i assure you we will not be back until one o'clock if you want to leave and go get something to eat.
Thank you.
Mike, do you know if we're live?
Are we recording?
Excellent.
Welcome to the committee conference on House Bill 2 one more time.
Would LBA passed out amendment number 2 0 2 1 dash 2 0 4 1 H in the name of Representative Packard, please.
Okay, just now on the other side.
I know we're doing this first.
Mr.
Speaker, how would you like to proceed?
Do you want LBA to run through the changes or would you like to do that, sir?
LBA, can you run through the changes in this amendment, please?
Sure.
Amendment number 2041H is similar to an amendment that was adopted by the committee yesterday relative to emergency powers with two main changes.
On page one on row 21, you will see a reference to subparagraph D.
Everything prior to that is the same.
Everything on the bottom of page one from lines 25 through 32 continued over through page two, row three are the same.
What is new is on beginning on page four, sorry, Beginning on page two, line four, subparagraph D, which is a new subsection, which states 90 days from the date of declaration of a state of emergency.
And every 90 days thereafter, the governor shall call pursuant to part two, article 50 of the New Hampshire Constitution, and address a joint session of the General Court and shall provide a written copy of the address to all members of both chambers within five business days.
At such joint session, the legislature shall either affirm the renewal or terminate the state of emergency by concurrent resolution adopted by a simple majority of both chambers acting separately on the following question.
Shall the current state of emergency be continued?
For purposes of this section, simple majority means a majority of members presenting voting, yay, in both chambers.
Note, and then we get to line 13, that is the relative to the fiscal committee, approval and accept and expands, as well as the exemption of the legislature to conduct their business.
No changes for yesterday's amendment from lines 13 through 28.
There is also no changes from yesterday's amendment on line 29, section 461 through 33.
On line 34, this is new.
This is a severability section, which states, beginning on line 34 on page 2, if any provision of RSA 445 as amended by this Act is declared unconstitutional or the applicability thereof to any person or circumstances held invalid, The constitutionality of the remainder RSA 445 and the applicability thereof to other persons in circumstances shall not be affected thereby.
And then the effective date on page three has just been adjusted accordingly to take into account the new section which was added.
Thank you, Mr.
King.
I will say the House position, which is quite a strong position.
We had this in a bill we had on the floor in the House.
And we had approximately 350 people vote in the affirmative to this language.
it was not partisan language it was bipartisan we strongly supported this language mr speaker would you like to speak in favor of your amendment no is there is there any discussion on the amendment we're in a time crunch do we have a motion motion on the amendment.
Representative umberger moves the adoption of amendment to zero to one dash to zero for one H represent Weiler seconds that motion.
See no hands up.
If the House is in favor favor would they please raise their hands for adopting the amendment we voted unanimously mr senate president senator favor senator the post the vote on this adoption is five to three one to zero Well, one to zero.
We should get one vote.
Thank you.
I've been calling the vote.
one to zero.
Well, one to zero.
We should get one vote.
Thank you.
I've been calling the votes wrong for three days.
Okay, it only matters today.
Senator Bradley.
Yes.
Thank you, Mickey.
Would you like to speak to your amendment or would you like Mr.
Kane?
Okay.
Senator Bradley.
So everybody got this amendment.
Okay, so this builds upon the language that speaker Packard just gave us, but let me walk through it.
There is a change on the first page of the amendment in lines 17 and 18.
the duration of the state of emergency would be set back to the statutory construct right now 21 days as opposed to 30 days so we're going we're shrinking the duration back to 21 days I believe this was something that uh representative Edwards brought to me this morning and I think it is sent it's meant to constrain a governor's authority.
What line was that?
That was page one, starts on 17, where it said 30 days, now 21 days, 18, 30 days, now 21 days.
30 days was a change, 21 days existing language is that correct that's correct.
We.
I am proposing on line three through 11 to incorporate virtually all of the speakers land I think we're on page two now.
Yes, I'm sorry ma'am page to line three through 11.
Thank you.
virtually all of the speakers language.
I think we're on page two now.
Yes, I'm sorry, ma'am.
Page two, line three through 11.
The change drops the words in the speaker's amendment shall affirm on line seven shall either affirm the renewal or terminate the state of emergency and substitutes the legislature shall vote on whether to terminate the state of emergency so i think some i think what both myself and the speaker are trying to accomplish is the following.
If there's a state of emergency in the state of New Hampshire, within 90 days, a governor would have to come before a joint session under Part 2, Article 50, and address both chambers in a joint session.
That is intended to provide transparency and accountability of an emergency order.
And then the legislature under this language shall vote on whether to terminate.
The rationale behind voting to terminate as opposed to affirm or terminate is the constitutional check and balance that we have in the state of New Hampshire under our Constitution, that one body of the legislature, either the House or the Senate, cannot override by itself.
And those are the traditional and constitutional checks and balances.
So if we have, as proposed on line seven, there has to be an affirmative vote and it has to be on whether it will terminate.
And that is, I hope the rationale and an acceptable way forward that provides the kind of transparency and accountability that I think all eight of us feel is necessary.
And it maintains our traditional constitutional checks and balances.
And lastly, the only, and it's really not a change, but it's a change from our amendment of yesterday, the severability clause at the bottom of the page.
And that's there for obvious reasons.
So thank you, Madam Chair.
You're welcome.
Seeing no discussion.
Is there a motion?
I will move the amendment.
Senator Bradley moves amendment 2 0 2 1 2 0 4 2 S.
Senator Morse seconds that motion.
The House, if you're in favor, please raise your hands.
We are not in favor.
Senator Morse, how does the Senate vote?
As I've just learned, the vote now is zero to one.
Is that correct?
It's two, which is exactly what this language that Senator Bradley presents would accomplish, because in the language the Speaker presented, one body can overrule the other body.
We will be, by vote, going with Amendment 2-0-2-1-2-0-4-1-H.
I have one more item.
Mr.
Cain, I'm on page 299 of the compare report.
And I have what I think is going to be 299 correct?
I said 299 I hope did I say 299?
I believe it.
Okay, now it's 299.
No matter what I said before.
In the bottom paragraph on section 356, Mr.
Kane, yesterday, I believe we moved that LBA could provide technical and maintenance corrections.
We would like the first date of January 1, 2022 to be moved to be March 31, 2022.
299 represent Bumberger.
We're in section 21 dash I colon 108.
The second date, which is October 1st, 2022.
We would like that moved to January 1st, 2023.
And I believe representative Edwards is going to be moving to the table in favor of representative Turcotte is that correct mr speaker this is a technical change does someone in the house move this technical change second representative umberger moves the approval of those two dates as read represent weiler seconds that motion second sooner or more seconds the motion we're going to put the vote with the House, please vote if you are in favor of having LBA make those technical changes for us.
We are unanimous.
This vote would be two to nothing now that I've correctly learned how to call the vote.
See, old dogs can learn new tricks.
I am a cat person.
Definitely.
Old cats can learn new tricks too.
At this point in time, we have concluded the work we're going to do.
Senator Morris, would you like to say something?
Well, i think the senate and lba wants to clarify where we are on the two no votes we just had and what's in the budget yes just to clarify based on the actions taken by the the two bodies on the two amendments offered today and the emergency orders And there was not a reconsideration of the vote on 2017 from yesterday.
We're going to maintain 2017.
We just wanted to make sure that the committee understands that.
Is that correct?
No, I'm sorry, Mike.
Okay.
I thought that 2041 actually says replace.
So that may be my fault because the OLS had replaced at the top.
So we are actually is there a motion to to reconsider 217.
2041 did not pass.
So that was why.
According to the clerk.
The chair can say if it will go into the report.
Okay.
So we'll put 204.1.H.
I've had a parliamentary lesson today also.
More than I wanted to have.
Thank you.
Okay, sure.
The Senate asking for recess.
A break.
Right.
Recess.
We're going to take a 10 minute recess.
I'm sorry.
Break.
I repeated Senator Morrison's words.
Thank you.
I think the record has been actually called out on another thing and we're going to ask Representative Emmerich who is one of our assigned alternates to sitting with us.
Senator Morris, when you raised your hand, I thought you were going to ask me if the House was acceding to the Senate on sections 356 to 361.
I'd be happy to ask you if the House is acceding to the Senate.
If the House is acceding, would you please raise your hand?
Yes, sir, we are.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
And I'm sorry I thought you were not.
I didn't realize you were still too back I wanted to finish that particular thing.
Senator Bradley, the House, if you don't mind, would like to ask that you re that we reconsider your amendment 2042 and ask you a couple of questions would that be acceptable absolutely um one of the things that got changed and i'm not certain i understand why is line nine the current state of emergency question.
And can you just explain that to me in the hall when I ask you, but could you explain to all of us again why that changed?
To line nine?
Page two, line nine, yes, sir.
So because of the way that the construct is that in line seven, the legislature shall vote on whether to terminate, the question has to be, shall the current state of emergency be terminated to keep it consistent with, as I said before, the checks and balances and the constitutional requirement that both bodies take an action.
And the action would be to terminate.
So that actually gives us the affirmative vote we were looking to ask and we misunderstood what was in your amendment?
To terminate an emergency order, yes.
Okay.
Thank you for that explanation.
I'll move to adopt amendment 2042 representative weiler moves to adopt amendment 2021-2042s senator daniels seconds okay now i wrote the vote on here before any more discussion seeing none is the House in favor of the motion to adopt to zero to one dash to oh four to West please raise your hand.
Okay, we had different outcome when we understood.
All right, Mr.
Cain.
I think now we understand we should have had a little more discussion.
We have now adopted 2021-2042s yes we do not want to have the motion the amendment we had yesterday do we have to move to reconsider both that down or can you take it out and because again this says replace we will replace what you did yesterday and this will replace it in its entirety okay and that's acceptable yes Mr alakonis will bring over the sign-off sheet so we can sign it off right here ah service with a smile we normally get a complete version of house bill 2 with everything in it.
However, we've made a couple of changes.
Is the committee comfortable allowing LBA to add that amendment, make the changes, and for us to vote off at this time?
I am, yes.
Do we have a motion to adopt House Bill 202 as amended?
So moved.
Second.
Representative Weiler moves, so no more seconds to adopt House Bill 2 as amended by this Committee of Conference.
If this House is in favor, please raise your hand.
Is the Senate in oh yippee two to nothing now that i've learned to call the vote correctly she she could have told me the first day you know i could have done that right all along um i guess mr kane we have arrived at the end i can tell you that this has been hard for all of us.
It takes a village.
It started in March for the House.
Division one would not have made it without Mike Hoffman and Nancy Levinas.
We had over 100 amendments.
We wouldn't have made it.
But I know Karen speaks the same way about Mickey.
And Kevin Ripple used to work with Division I before he went to Division III.
And Jess Edwards quickly learned how valuable he was.
Mr.
Cain and Mr.
Shea, your team has been wonderful.
And I would like to give you a standing ovation from all of us.
We always wanted to thank people from OLS.
Janet Klayman, our secretary, we almost have to put shackles on her.
Is she in there?
No, she's left.
She does this to us all the time.
She hates to have the knowledge.
She doesn't want to have her hand in here, but I can.
Janet.
Okay, Janet.
from a house perspective and i have a feeling Senator Morris would and Senator Daniels would concur with this.
We had a great deal of help from the budget director, Matt Malou.
He was just instrumental, answered technical questions, helped with wording when we had questions.
Chris Elm came over.
We had committee chairman from many of the standing committees in the House.
It really takes a village to get this done.
Aaron Goulet, our chief of staff, I know Deb Vanderbeek, the Senate chief of staff, and Josh Elliott, the deputy on the Senate, Deborah Childs, the deputy on our side, helped in innumerable ways that you cannot imagine.
We've done a fiscally balanced budget.
We have a lot of positive things in here.
We had more agreement than disagreement.
And we have managed, ladies and gentlemen, to reach the end successfully.
Thank you.
more agreement than disagreement.
And we have managed, ladies and gentlemen, to reach the end successfully.
So thank you.
Thank you.
Before we sign off, I just want to make it clear that the chairman of this committee, and I called and told her this, done an unbelievable job of keeping us in line and running a committee that had a lot to go over.
And I applaud all your work, Madam Chair.
Thank you.
It was an honor.
Thank you very much.
I'm going to pile on if I could.
I think it's really important to cite Representative and all our House colleagues, but Representative Ober, for the honesty, the integrity, the attention to detail that you've brought.
I think this is the first committee of conference in all these years that we've been in this building together that I've been on with you.
And you're on the tightest of tight ships now i know you're going on a ship around you know iceland please come back soon and and have a good summer and good rest you deserve it thank you thank you very much okay guys I'm going to be like Janet.
I'm going to go in the other room.
We are done.
We are expecting OLS to come with the sign-off sheet.
So if you'll hang around, we will get that done.
Mr.
Kane, committee conference members may want to have a copy of HB2.
When might that be available?
We'll get you something as soon as possible.
Most of us are going to be up here Friday anyway.
Yes, we can have copies.
Which is tomorrow because fiscal is going to be here.
Fiscal is meeting tomorrow.
I'll have copies of the surplus statement as well.
You are balanced as you stated.
I'll have copies of the detailed surplus statement as well.
I'll email tonight.
Thank you.
We're adjourned.
All right.